rescuers don't expect to find anyone
else alive and you can see why
they know people trapped beneath this
heavy rubble stood little chance as the
fire took hold
this is how rapidly and ruthlessly life
can change for ukrainians in this
needless war
innocent shoppers far from the front
line
killed
wounded
missing
this has become a grim recovery
operation now rescuers have told me
they found human remains which makes it
very hard for them to know how many
people have died at this stage
but dozens remain missing and a local
police station is collecting dna from
their loved ones
outside one hospital we meet a mother
desperately looking for her daughter
[Music]
tetiana was 22 years old and worked in a
mobile phone store at the shopping
center
inside at 25 patients from monday's
attack
father of two ihor was shopping for
computer accessories and saw the
missiles hit
[Music]
in this ward of four men it became clear
the invisible injuries were taking a
greater toll
um
we found no evidence to support russia's
claim the shopping center caught fire
from a strike on a nearby military
target so it might be that you guys do
the friendships war crimes investigators
at the scene told us it was hard to see
any justifiable military logic to an
action such as this
and the prosecutor general is
investigating why the shopping center
wasn't evacuated when the air raid siren
sounded
don't be relaxed when you are in war and
people should be uh should understand it
that we should wait from our enemy such
missiles every minute and be ready
there's a growing sense of anxiety among
civilians here that nowhere in ukraine
is safe
sally lockwood sky news kremenchuk